this is a production of Cornell
University
so I wanted to talk
um today about food waste and its land
use implications these this is a quote
these are the first lines actually of
Tristram Stewart's book on food waste
which was first published in 2009 and I
think his book remains one of the most
comprehensive and well-researched yet
still very broadly accessible books on
food waste and what he's talking about
here is the very rapid conversion of Our
Land Resources into fields and food
factories
um and you know we can take that Insight
um or that fact into lots of different
directions and Stewart's focus and the
focus of my research is on food waste so
here is the here is the very same
information in graphic form
um this graph uh uses information from
the FAO the first row of it
um is just shows that just 29 of the
earth's surface is land the second row
shows that about 71 percent of that land
is habitable the rest of it is Glacier
or desert or salt flat or some other
formation that makes it unfit for human
habitation the third row which I think
is the key line in the graph is that we
are currently using half of that for
agriculture about 37 percent of the
remainder is forested 11 is is shrubland
within and very tiny proportions that
make up our cities and fresh water sort
of waterways
so when we expand agricultural
production we're increasing the amount
of forested land and the carbon sinks
that we have and then continuing on
those bottom three rows what you can see
there is that when you look at how we
use that agricultural land most of it's
used to produce livestock so it's used
either for grazing or to produce feed
for livestock and that's mostly soy and
corn but last two lines the last two
rows most of our calories and even most
of our protein don't come from meat and
dairy they come from plant-based crops
which are grown on a very small
proportion of our agricultural land so I
think that that graphic packs a lot of
information
onto one page this is a actually a
different visual of the same process
this was the Brazilian Amazon just a
couple of years ago in 2019
the dynamic underpinning the fires was
the clearing of the forest for the
expansion of soybean farming in South
America there was a particular push at
that time to put more land under
cultivation because of the trade war
between the U.S and China that you may
remember but as that map on the right
shows or at least the right of my screen
shows
um
in Argentina and Olivia and Paraguay and
Brazil forest was cleared and grasslands
were converted into soybean plantations
on a massive scale so since the 1970s
over half of the Serato in Brazil which
is the most probably the most biodiverse
Savannah in the world has been turned
into agricultural fields and so the
burning of this this particular
incident became a global story because
it was the Amazon and because of the
very high profile trade war with China
but the destruction of forested land is
happening much more quietly on an
ongoing basis all over the world and
food loss and food waste are directly
implicated in those Dynamics and of
course in climate change if we wasted
less of the food that we produced there
would be less pressure to clear more of
this land so at the U.N food Summit this
past fall it was estimated that the
amount of land and we use to produce
food that's lost or wasted is greater
than the size of China which means
greater than the size of the United
States right and that's that's a that's
a lot of land to be clearing and using
to produce food that no one ever eats
um these are uh here are two Graphics
from a very recent report called the
food waste index that's by the United
Nations environment program or unep
numbers I will say are very tricky when
it comes to food waste we don't have a
lot of great data on food loss and food
waste so it's been difficult to quantify
it to measure it and therefore to
measure our progress on reducing it so I
would treat all numbers as
approximations
but most of the time we say that about
one-third of the food that we produce is
lost or wasted and this recent unept
report actually suggests that the
problem may be even larger than that so
just terminology we we generally use the
term food loss to refer to food that is
lost in the production in the processing
stages before it ever reaches a retail
outlet or the consumer so food that was
damaged in the field or food that was
simply not harvested because of cosmetic
standards for some other reason or food
that's spoiled in storage or on the way
from the farm to the processing plant
that would be food loss and that's a
major problem in poor countries in
particular because of a lack of reliable
transportation lack of
climate-controlled storage facilities we
use the term food waste and that's the
subject of this of this unep report to
refer to food that is not sold or eaten
at the retail of a food service or the
consumer end of the of the supply chain
so we used to think that food waste was
more prevalent in wealthy countries than
in poor countries this unep court report
actually challenges that idea one of the
key findings from the report is that
household food waste is a problem across
income levels
so it's problem in poorer countries just
as it is in wealthy ones and we need to
pay attention to it everywhere another
Finding from this report is that food
waste in households may be twice as high
as we previously thought
so the graphic on the left shows that
households are the source of most food
waste followed by food service and in
retail and the graphic on the right
breaks this down by country so countries
with large populations like China and
India understandably produce in net
terms the most food waste and that's
what the orange bars there depict but
the yellow circles on the right show
food waste per capita right and the
picture there is
um that some countries are more wasteful
than others on a per capita basis
Australia in this case comes out on top
um with 102 kilograms of food per person
per year it's about 225 pounds so
broadly the picture that emerges from
the unep report is that no matter how
you measure it food waste is a huge
problem practically everywhere in the
world so
um
food waste under anaerobic conditions in
landfills for example produces methane
we all know that and that's of course a
problem but when we waste food the part
that many people don't think about is
that we waste a lot of embedded energy
or a lot of resources that have gone
into producing that food in the and I
already mentioned that the amount of
land we use to produce food that's lost
or wasted is greater than the size of
China or the United States also at the
U.N food Summit this past fall
presenters noted that about a quarter of
the world's freshwater resources that
are used for agriculture go into food
that's lost or wasted meat and dairy
products are particularly resource
intensive to produce you saw that in
terms of the land that's devoted to
animal production but meat and dairy
also require an enormous amount of water
one hamburger in this case from the
Sierra Club takes about 600 gallons of
of water to produce so when we waste
food we not only create greenhouse gases
in the way that we dispose of it but we
also want the energy and the resources
that are embedded in that food the land
the water the nutrients that were
required to grow it and produce it the
feel the fuel that we used to transport
it from one place to another other and
the energy that was required to store it
to cook it and so and so on
so
um
these are food recovery hierarchies many
of you've probably seen these and know
these there are many different versions
of this hierarchy I'm showing you the
one on the left from the EPA one on the
right from the European environmental
agency and what these show are different
strategies and different priorities for
managing wasted or excess or surplus
food and there will always be Surplus
that's what food security is about
Surplus is a good thing within limits
but what we do with that Surplus is
important and so at the top is the most
preferred strategy which is Source
reduction or actually prevention which
means not producing waste in the first
place or reducing the amount of surplus
that we produce and at the bottom is the
least preferred strategy for managing
food waste and that's putting it in a
landfill so the strategies at the top
create the most benefits for the
environment and also society and the
economy the strategies toward the bottom
create the fewest benefit it's and what
we currently do is actually the inverse
of this we currently landfill most of
the food we waste we compost a very
small proportion of it and we convert an
even smaller amount into energy through
biodigestion
um and animal feed so in other words we
have a we have a very linear food system
production consumption disposal rather
than a circular one you will also note
on the on this EPA hierarchy that among
the recycling strategies after you get
past donation and and feeding hungry
people the rest of those are recycling
strategies among them feeding scraps to
animals is the preferred recycling
strategy more than digestion or waste
energy and more than composting and
that's because it keeps food in the
human food supply chain
so one of the takeaways from the land
use graph that I showed earlier is that
we should all be eating more plant-based
diets I think we can probably conclude
that from those data but animal protein
is a really important part of many
people's diets around the world it's
very important to nutritional security
and food Security in many places
um so you know I think there is the
question of how do we find ways to
produce animal protein that's less land
and resource intensive and there's a lot
of good research being done on this
right now including some by some of my
colleagues in the department of global
development these are just a couple of
their Publications there's also a lot of
on-the-ground experimentation with
closed loop or circular production
systems this is kipster which is a Dutch
company that's producing Net Zero carbon
eggs in part through feeding chickens
entirely on food scraps rather than
using land to produce feed this
particular company is expanding to the
U.S we also have some models of this on
a smaller scale in the U.S already
in New York in New York state the policy
environment for pushing experimentation
on this front became much more favorable
this year as New York state became on
January 1st the sixth state in the
country to adopt a commercial organic
span
the bans in these states that are
highlighted here in the Northeast and in
California there are also some
municipalities that have commercial
Organics bands
are all very different in character the
one in New York applies to generators
that produce two tons of excess food per
week or more so colleges supermarkets
restaurants pretty large scale
commercial entities in New York
generators have to donate edible food to
food banks and to food pantries and they
have to recycle food scraps as long as
there's a recycling facility within 25
miles of of their operation
and so recycling could be any one of
those strategies that I showed you in
the food recovery hierarchy it could be
feeding scraps to animals it could be
digestion it could be composting and the
expectation is that these these bands
this new policy will lead to New Markets
to new experiments and to new
infrastructure in the state and that's
if you look at what happened in some of
the other states you can see the impetus
that policy that provides in in Vermont
for example which is the state that I
think has the most expansive food waste
ban no food waste goes to landfill it is
all it all has to be recycled including
at the household level
um so I'm right now I'm doing some
research with the or for the Department
of Environmental Conservation in New
York on the opportunities and
constraints related to feeding food
scraps to animals there are constraints
but there are also lots of opportunities
and some really interesting models for
how to how to do this there's a as I I
think alluded to just
um the slide ago there's a small scale
company in Vermont that's doing the same
thing as kipster there are Dairy Farmers
there are pig Farmers feeding scraps to
their animals and in some cases raising
their animals on a diet made up entirely
or almost entirely of food scraps and in
some cases that has required important
changes including working with
particular breeds of animals and a lot
of research and a lot of experimentation
so I don't have time to talk a lot about
that my project
today I hope I can do that at some later
date but I'll just end by saying that
there's a lot of work being done
um to reduce the food feed competition
and to reduce the amount of land that's
used to grow crops to feed animals
um so I would just close with this quote
reducing food waste and creating
circular systems and keeping food in the
human food supply chain is right at the
center of many of these questions about
land use if we don't want to continue to
convert forests into fields we need to
deal with our food waste problem and in
addition to eating more plant-based
diets that means producing animal
proteins in much more environmentally
friendly ways and feeding our food
scraps to animals may be one of them so
so thanks very much
and I hope maybe there's time for some
questions there is definitely time for
some questions
um but nobody has posted a question so
uh I guess what is one of the most
Innovative food recovery strategies that
you've seen that is exciting to you
um you know blue hill at Stone barns
um is
um you know A very upscale restaurant in
the Hudson Valley and they are
um feeding their pigs entirely on
recovered materials so Brewers grains
but also kitchen scraps
um and so forth and they have done a
tremendous amount of experimentation
they have
um changed the breed of pig that they
raise to do that and that's you know
that that's perhaps not a a great
example because that's a um a place that
can charge a premium for their product
um there are I'll say that what there
tend to be are very
um
scaled up versions of food scrap
recovery and feed production or very
small scale sort of Mom and Pop level
kinds of operations so an example
Connecticut is doing there's a really
interesting project underway there a
food scrap recycler is building an
enormous facility that should have the
capacity to collect all the food scraps
in the state of Connecticut it's pretty
centrally located and they're going to
be producing pellets for animal feed
um
that they're not they're under
construction now it's not operational
yet uh but their equivalent of the
Department of Environmental Conservation
in Connecticut is very excited about the
capacity
um that they're going to have to recycle
nearly all the food scraps um in the
state in that way in New York there are
lots of um there there are a couple
there I think there's one example of a
very large scale
um
uh
food waste collector uh who is producing
animal feed it's a bakery mix it's
mostly products from bakeries and you
know cookies candies those kinds of
things that
um he then sells to Dairy Farmers and
cattle Farmers across the Northeast even
into Canada and that mix can make up
about four to six percent of the ration
of the dairy ration
um much more common are very sort of
small scale operations where smaller
scale farmers will have a relationship
with a local store or a local restaurant
and we'll pick up food scraps and and
feed them at home there are there have
been some Innovative
um
you know sort of pet food applications
um those don't really count in terms of
um
you know keeping food scraps in the
human food chain so
um they're not considered
um the food scrap recycling at least for
the purposes of
um the epa's hierarchy
but so so there are so large scale small
scale and some models emerging as people
try to figure this out
eat so Sycamore May asks Lori do you
know if there's any work being done on
the FDA to feed compost to commercial
livestock like chickens for example do
you know if the livestocks get the
nutrients they need from compost
um there is a very interesting operation
in Vermont
um that is a vertically integrated Farm
it's a composting farm that feeds
chickens entirely on food scraps
um and allows the chickens to sort of
pick around the food scraps
um to get what they want and it's it's a
laying operation
um and so it's very much like hipster
it's the it's the example that I was
that I was giving when I was speaking
about the kipster Farms
um and the operator of that has really
done a lot of research and is a very uh
you know uh I would say
um this is not a backyard operation it's
a very well researched uh
thing that he's doing and uh it's a it's
local I mean it's an extremely localized
uh operation he
um collects food scraps from within his
municipality and he sells his eggs
within his municipality
um but he's been and he has a pretty
small size flock as egg layers Go I mean
they it's 300 300 laying hens it's not
tiny but it's not uh you know it's not I
think the egg production has been become
so
um concentrated that it's certainly not
a large scale operation but at that at
that scale I think he's been very
successful
so David K asks since you took a Global
Perspective initially can you talk about
how aspects and especially solutions to
the waste issue tend to vary by location
in the world in general and by location
with the us as well
how the uh could you repeat that one
more time could you talk about how
aspects and especially solutions to the
waste issue tend to vary by location in
the world or in the U.S as well yeah
um
well I I mean I I think in the U.S
um the you know we have a patchwork we
have a patchwork of laws
um that vary by state and by
municipality and
that makes it tough because especially
if you look at the at the Northeast
um
we don't necessarily uh you know respect
state borders there's a lot of
cross-border traffic and so you know the
the person who uh started the The
Chicken Farm in Vermont actually was a
New York resident and moved to Vermont
because uh the legislation there made it
easier for him to do his operation in
Vermont instead of New York
um so I think that there's a there's a
you know and we have the same thing
around date labeling if you look at uh
the date labeling laws if you're a
manufacturer and you sell to multiple
States you're going to
um take the most conservative stance on
you know that exists in any state and
you're going to use it because you want
to be able to sell in that state
um it's not necessarily the most
favorable uh application for you know
reducing food waste because of confusion
over date labels but of course that's
what you know manufacturers who sell
across state borders are going to do so
I think there's a there's a we have we
have some
um Federal standards cosmetic standards
grading standards around apples for
example that allow both interstate and
cross-country Commerce to proceed with
people knowing what they're going to get
but we have a lot of
um state by state and even municipality
by municipality kinds of laws and
policies that really do impact food
waste for the most part in New York we
don't require date labels but there are
a few counties and I think
there's one of them that requires date
labels on dairy products and you know
that sort of sets the tone for the whole
state and Beyond
another question affirm is Susan Holcomb
do you have an opinion about Pastor
raised and finished animals
well I think
um this is interesting because uh you
know one of the uh things that we've
heard a lot in our research
um is that farmers are very worried
about finishing times
and you know Blue Hills uh you know
talks about it does take longer the
finishing times for their pigs are
longer than they would be if they didn't
use
um food scraps
uh and a lot of pig farmers in New York
there aren't uh there's I think a
dwindling number of uh pig farms in the
state but a lot of pig farmers will say
that there are so few butchering
facilities that they have to book times
to slaughter their animals
almost as the animals are born and so
there's really no margin for error in
terms of you know finishing them that
has become a so I think our food system
the way we think about the production of
animals the way we the timelines that
that requires in order for them to that
that operation to be profitable actually
determines
um you know our ability to
um to think about using food scraps for
animal feed
um in in really fundamental ways so um I
would say that
um
that distinction is is I mean I that
that's how I would think about that
distinction that I think a lot of people
um uh really think about that getting
animals to wait at a particular time and
they need to do whatever it takes to get
there
okay my last question for you is can you
just briefly describe uh your DEC report
and when it will be released and of
course we will invite you back to
present on that but uh I just want to
let everybody know about this work that
you're doing so that they can be primed
and ready to receive it when you release
it oh thank you so the dec project and
report and I should say it's also funded
by nifa and a hatch Grant
um was was to look at the opportunities
and constraints related to diverting
more of our food scraps uh to animals
into animal feed across the state
um
uh so it it will be ready this summer uh
it will be coming out this summer and we
are still we've done a lot of interviews
with generators we've done a lot of
interviews with uh farmers who are using
uh food scraps on farms we've done a lot
of interviews with State officials in
other states that have introduced
Organics bands before New York to find
out how they promoted this or what's
happening in their states around the
diversion of food scraps to animal feed
we've interviewed Mills and others who
are producing rations and animal
nutritionists and now what we're doing
is making site visits to innovators
um you know farmers who are going to a
Dairy next week that they're using food
scraps to feed their cows
um and so uh we hope that these case
studies are useful to you to people as
well so Jenny it is coming out this
summer and
um be happy to talk about it in the fall
fantastic
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu